special thanks to opera gx for
sponsoring this video
last week we transformed the artwork of
dragon ball super superhero and this
week we've taken your suggestions and
boy do we have something special in
store for you today apart from
dedicating countless hours of pain and
suffering to make these videos possible
we'll also be drawing in the styles of
yuya takahashi and naotoshi shida to
name but a few and what's more is i have
a little announcement to make
first a quick word from our sponsor
it's always nice when sponsors reach out
with products i actually use and opera
gx is a browser that's technically built
for gamers but actually offers by far
the best features of any browser that
even us lovely weebs will enjoy the
advantages of it's probably most
famously known for its ability to
monitor and limit the resources that
tabs are taking up which is a real dream
when i'm doing any sort of editing but
it actually has a lot more to offer than
just that one of the coolest features is
the sheer customization and offer with
opera gx there's an absolute wealth of
custom wallpapers especially the
animated ones from the opera add-on
section maybe it sounds kind of dorky
but i actually do enjoy building little
themes around anime i love you can also
upload your own images and adjust the
colors to match along with this one of
my favorite aspects is the light and
dark modes especially the auto adjusting
one which is probably the best i've seen
from a browser for me personally one of
the most useful features is the video
pop-out one i'm oftentimes pulling up
episodes to refresh my memory when
writing scripts so being able to float
an adjustable video frame over my work
is so unbelievably helpful and i'm sure
those of you who watch my videos and
study will get some great use out of
them too it's honestly such a great
browser for productivity you can log
into things like spotify apple music and
youtube music directly from within the
browser but what i love the most is that
it detects when you open up a video in a
tab and automatically pauses your music
for you no more awkwardly all tapping to
pause just because you want to watch a
youtube video i know swapping browsers
can be a real pain given you've likely
got years of usage in your preferred one
but opera gx makes changing faster than
goku's instant transmission with just a
few clicks your browsing history
bookmarks and cookies and general
settings are seamlessly transferred it
really is as simple as that so if you
want to make the swap simply click my
link down in the description and
download opera gx today
in addition to the video you're about to
watch now earlier this week i reached
out to numerous professional animators
that have and worked for toy animation
to see if they'd like to give these
redraws a shot themselves and they
responded which means next week
professional toy animation animators
will be redrawing some of the stills
from these trailers in your favorite art
styles
everyone on the team is very excited for
the upcoming dragon ball super superhero
film and this is our way of showing that
excitement i can't wait to share it with
you all but for now it's time for this
week's video last time i asked you guys
to send us suggestions and suggestions
you most definitely sent us one of the
most popular ones sent away was this
image of piccolo charging his special
beam cannon
and the artist first up in the chopping
block to attempt this redraw is
me okay awesome i love piccolo and you
know what i want to redeem myself from
last week's struggle so i'm gonna draw
this in the crazy detail style of masaki
sato
and you know what this one was actually
all right now in saying that as i
mentioned last week misaki sado is known
for his rugged detailed and specific
style that colored a lot of early dragon
ball z but to be honest i don't mind
spending more time drawing details when
i know the result is going to be worth
it last time it felt like i was really
spinning my wheels but this week i had
some really nice references particularly
from the dragon ball z films as well as
this piece of gengar showing a close-up
of piccolo's face you might have also
noticed that at this point i went to the
trouble of drawing all the lines in
piccolo's arms this was a mistake and it
was also before i realized that in the
film piccolo has some new form where
he's colored slightly differently and
doesn't have those lines in his arms
something about the arms just doesn't
look right without them and you know
what it'll probably look great in the
movie but in the end i was honestly
really happy with how this one turned
out let's see how this one looks once aj
applies that old-school filter one two
three wow okay uh big change thanks for
helping me look good aj i think this
looks awesome
next image up to draw is
oh it's one of my favorite stills from
the trailers it's vegeta in a
foreshortened fighting pose and the
artist that's up next to draw is
trev in the style of
yuya takahashi this should be good for
those of you that don't know yuya
takahashi is one of the most prolific
action animators of the modern era
producing some of the craziest sequences
from both dragon ball super and the
dragon ball super broly film like is the
case with many of the drawings we're
doing in this video there are no fixes
being made to the cgi frames necessarily
just different approaches taken as you
can see with this redraw most of the
changes trev implements are really
stylistic more than anything reforming
the face to be more in line with a more
traditional approach while keeping the
anatomy largely the same if the trailers
are any indication to go by the film
itself looks fantastic and this is
coming from someone that was a little
nervous considering how hit or miss cgi
can be at times with anime productions
but i think we're all glad this movie is
getting the treatment it deserves
furthermore i think i can speak for the
team when i say that these colors on
beerus's world and the trailers honestly
look stunning which is why we kept them
the pink and purple hues really add to
the cgi renders as well as the 2d
visuals trevor's stream rolling through
right here as you can see trev is also
using the 1.5 pixel thick anti-aliasing
brush which means once again we required
the services of mix our resident broly
filter expert let's see how it looks
once we apply that filter one two three
mix thank you very much his socials will
be in the description down below and
this might actually be my favorite image
trev has produced on this series so far
but i think there's still one drawing in
this video he does even better next up
is this really awesome image of gohan
and gama clashing in the heat of battle
and the artist up to draw this time is
our resident mouse wielding expert aj in
the style of none other than the man
who's as talented as he is polarizing
naoki tate
having sat out the last video due to
illness we noticed that hundreds of you
guys were asking about aj's whereabouts
and thanks to your very inquisitive
nature i managed to drag both him and
his mouse kicking and screaming into
this video aj decided to draw with a
tablet today all to replicate a very
distinct style that people either love
or hate these days in animation the less
detail there is and the more soft the
designs are with characters typically
the easier it is to animate with and due
to this nauki tate despite dragon ball
super's notoriously brutal schedule
consistently delivered some of the best
movement during its entire run however
this is very much a taste thing in this
instance some folks don't care as much
about movement and want more model
correctness above all else personally i
love tate's style and i think aj is
killing it with this drawing the rounder
jaws interesting mouth shapes as well as
the blobby round shading all pulled
their weight in painting this very tate
picture but as we mentioned with trev's
vegeta it's only half the battle as
mixes needed to apply the filters and
effects so let's see how they look once
they're applied one two three
ooh now this one looks awesome i think
regardless of where you sit in the fence
with regards now kitate aj drew
something truly brilliant here please
give him props something this video
needs more of however is paint and i'm
willing to supply that as next is the
drawing of goten and trunks as young
adults i'm drawing it and i decided to
try and copy the style that defined
dragon ball gt and i wish i didn't
this one was honestly one of the only
shots i thought looked kind of off what
with trunks's head leaning forward sort
of unnaturally and so i thought this
would be a great opportunity to flex
with my anatomy knowledge spoiler alert
i have no anatomy knowledge in addition
to that upon accepting this challenge i
soon realized that i didn't even really
know what made dragon ball gt different
to dragon ball z i wasn't nearly as
familiar with that series as i was the
original dragon ball and because of that
i drew weird faces like these thinking
that the most important thing was to
draw big noses and chins i guess and by
the way did you know it's really hard to
find reference images at this angle for
these characters in dragon ball gt like
the three-quarter downward shot there's
a strange amount of up shots in dragon
ball gt that wasn't in the prior series
which honestly i thought contributed to
this weird sense that everyone in the
series had these massive chins but it
was just every shot was from like an
upward angle it's weird regardless i
needed to once again accept i wasn't
going to be able to do this one alone
and that's when trev stepped in to lend
a hand with the faces thankfully i was
somewhat happy with the bodies i made
for the most part and could source
colors from the gt series itself and to
round everything off it's time for aj to
help me look good in one two three
beautiful i'm not accepting this as my
drawing by the way this one was most
definitely a team effort it would have
looked truly awful without the help i
got on this one so thanks everybody
switching gears from that on to
something completely different this cute
image of pan powering up and the artist
tasked with this one was
editor san and in the style of
classic minoru maeda minora maeda was
the very first character designer on the
dragon ball series working on the show
from 1986 all the way to 1993 well into
the dragon ball z material of the story
before being taken over by nakatsuru and
tadayoshi yamamuro and while this pose
and image might look simple this one
poses one of the toughest challenges
ironically as many artists who have
attempted toriyama's early dragon ball
style can attest while it might look
minimalistic and simple it's that very
minimalism that causes so many problems
for artists when trying to emulate that
style because there are so few markers
or details in these designs that define
them if one feature or marker is even a
little out of place then suddenly it all
looks wrong which means you need to be
very familiar with this particular style
in order to pull it off and we all had
trouble trying to get this one right
thankfully though we have a great team
and editor-san was able to illustrate
something that looks supremely evocative
of that period in anime history
transforming a character that in every
sense of the word was emblematic of
toriyama's modern designs into one that
was faithful to the original simple
approach now all we have to do is apply
the filter and one two three
i think every time i look at this it
gets better and even more authentic
looking amazing work editor sam next
image up for reimagination is this sweet
shot of gamma number one and gamma
number two and the artist tasked with
changing it is
me
and the style
masaki sado again all right let's do
this these two honestly look like
they'll start out the film as
antagonists but by the end will be
unlikely allies against whatever the big
bad will end up being but because i love
masaki sado's angular style i decided to
reference a lot of the older dragon ball
z films with garlic jr and piccolo to
see what sort of angular concoction i
could come up with for these fine
fellows i think i like following these
older design philosophies as the style
these fellows were conceptualized in was
that of modern toriyama thinner lankier
features with softer rounder shapes they
look great but i think part of what
makes these sorts of videos interesting
has to be the contrast and masaki sato's
angular sharper style in z makes for the
perfect contrast to these modern
toriyama characters and surprisingly
this one out of all the drawings this
week was the easiest to draw for me the
absence of a nose was troubling but i
looked at junemba to see how the
character designers navigated that and
using that same genemba image sourced
the colors that helped bring this image
to completion this was a totally
painless and dare i say fun enterprise
now all aj has to do is apply the
filters one two three
and there you have it some old-timey
gamma number one and gamma number two
ready to cause all sorts of trouble for
the z warriors next image up is actually
the most requested this sixth shot of
ultimate gohan and drawing this will be
treb in the style of yuya takahashi
i think the trouble with trev's drawings
is that they are often over in the blink
of an eye when it comes to a variety of
dragon ball art styles trev seems to
have them down packed often times when
someone begins drawing a dragon ball
character they do so with the face i
mean i'm guilty of this however when it
comes to drawing anything for trev good
fundamentals are key and trev starts all
of these off with a solid base sketch
layer to make sure the construction is
how he wants it from there he will
slowly tweak and build his character
design and structure off of each
subsequent layer applying takahashi
style idiosyncrasies as he progresses
towards the finished product sharp
angular eyes with a great sense of
intensity adjusting the size and
positioning of different muscle groups
and body features as he goes to ensure a
faithful result to the inspiration
itself with shading playing a large part
in what helps takahashi stand out from
the modern era applying old-school
shading philosophy and now all trev has
to do is line it with the anti-aliasing
pixel brush and he's done mix time to
add that filter one two three
this is awesome and mix you did some
great work too by adding your own
effects work to it it looks awesome
this next segment coming up is going to
be a little different we had a lot of
drawings to do this week and i wanted to
keep this video relatively short you
guys suggested we redo some of the promo
material for the film itself so for this
segment we will be drawing this image of
goku this image of hot pepper vegeta and
this promo image of goten and trunks and
the artists to draw them will be trev
myself and editor san respectively first
up is trev with his goku and he will be
drawing it in the style of shintani now
hiroshintani's style is delicate and
subtle but a wonderful one to work with
for the purposes of animation he goes
for a less is more approach and overall
a very round look to his drawings and
trev absolutely nails this one check out
that before and after
next up is myself with this vegeta and i
will be drawing in the style of minoru
maeda during the time of the saiyan saga
minora my ada was the character designer
for the series and this was where i took
most of my references from i wanted to
make sure i nailed his white set
shoulders and for color i even decided
to go that extra mile and tried to mimic
his watercolor vegeta manga i was very
pleased with how this one turned out and
compared to the original
and tackling this promo of goten and
trunks we have editor san in the style
of modern toriyama modern toriyama is a
tricky one to get right at least for me
and toriyama has a very particular way
of drawing characters those of you that
are unfamiliar with the kansan ban this
was a printed re-release of the original
dragon ball manga which featured new
toriyama artwork on their respective
covers which is exactly what editor-san
was going for with this one awesome work
just look at that comparison alright so
this brings us to the final image we
will be drawing this week and for that
we wanted to make it special the image
in question is this action shot of gohan
throwing his elbows towards the camera
and trev will be the artist drawing
and in the style of none other than the
iconic naotoshi shida naotoshi shida has
been an animator on dragon ball for
decades like many other prominent
animators like naoke tate masahiro
shimanuki and tarayoshi yamamuro
naotoshi shida cut his teeth with the
original series before becoming one of
the most highly regarded action
animators to have worked on dragon ball
ever he's responsible for some of the
most mind-bending scenes from battle of
gods the dragon ball super series and
indeed dragon ball super broly with his
signature style utilizing a ton of
extreme angles camera shakes strong
posing and of course sharp and detailed
shading work to help his images fly off
of the page once again the basic
structure for the most part with this 3d
bass structure was a great jumping off
point and gave trev the freedom to
immediately dive into the style of shita
without delay there's a sort of kinetic
intensity to his style and i genuinely
think trev absolutely nailed this one
all we have to do is apply mix's filter
to it one two three
wow that genuinely looks like something
straight from the anime or even dragon
ball super broly incredible work trev
and incredible work to everyone who
worked on these last two videos next
week professional animators that work
for toei will be joining us to help
bring these frames into the 2d world and
i hope you will join us for that very
special video if you don't want to miss
it be sure to like and subscribe but
until then i've been totally not mark
i'll see you all next weekend thank you
so much for watching
[Music]